well spring is here and the days are
warming up and that means pool season is
almost here we can feel it bianca
holmen's live and bianca talking about
important safety information before you
ever take a dip especially if you have
new swimmers in your household right
most definitely and sherry i think we're
all ready to lay by the pool sip
something cold but as you clean out your
backyard pools and as you grab your
passes for cowabunga bay we want you to
listen up is not only getting ready to
be pool season as the temperatures warm
up but it's also drowning season
so drowning season is just really really
heartbreaking time for us in southern
nevada drowning is actually the leading
cause of un
injury related deaths for young children
in our community water safety advocates
say now is the time to sign up for swim
lessons and children as young as six
months can start
water preparation starts really really
early it's getting kids comfortable in
the water you know even just being able
to put their ears in the water learning
to blow bubbles so that they don't get
water in their mouth and nose you know
it starts really really young and then
we do progress through the levels all
the way up until you know 13.
so there are actually three aspects of
water safety to keep in mind patrol
there should be a designated water
watcher anytime children are in or near
the water protect install barriers
between your children and the pool be
sure gates are locked and doors are
locked when again they're not out at the
pool without an adult and then be
prepared create a water safety plan and
be sure the water watcher can administer
cpr if there were to be an emergency and
also it's not just pools it can even be
kiddie pools it can be baths it can also
even be a bucket of water anytime
they're standing water and their
children around you want to be sure that
an adult is present so coming up in the
next half hour we're actually going to
talk about those who are keeping us safe
in the water and what clark county is
doing to recruit new lifeguards bianca
holman live local now